quand est ce que je serai remboursé
puis je faire une cure thermale cette
année je pars en vacances à l'étranger
est ce que ma mutuelle voyage avec moi
vous avez toujours plein de question
pour nous et c'est tant mieux car nous
sommes là pour y répondre
téléphonez nous ou demander à être
rappelé tout est clair et précis sur
notre site
une mutuelle qui vit avec vous votre
quotidien
c'est ça une mutuelle qui va bien
revenez clic et on en parle
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
check-up votre émission santé et
bien-être
au programme de ce numéro la ville de
coignières a inauguré un nouveau pôle
santé pluridisciplinaires un
établissement de 520 m² conforme
nouvelle loi sur l'accessibilité aux
personnes à mobilité réduite pour la
journée internationale du handicap le 9
décembre
le château de versailles a organisé une
semaine complète autour du handicap en
partenariat avec la fondation
d'entreprise française des jeux et la
croix rouge
nous irons ensuite au centre hospitalier
de versailles où l'association rire 78 a
lancé son action rire pour guérir retour
sur le spectacle de sophie forte et
régis moreau et pour finir un fort chez
diététicienne à chaville vous livrera
quelques conseils pour éviter les
lendemains difficiles
après les périodes de fêtes mais tout
d'abord la commune de la verrière
continue à se mobiliser contre la
fermeture de sa pmi la protection
maternelle et infantile qui se charge de
l'accompagnement des futures mamans et
du suivi des enfants de moins de 6 ans
une fermeture envisagée en début d'année
2016 par le conseil départemental afin
d'optimiser les moyens et d'effectuer
des économies
la municipalité entend maintenir la
pression sur le président du conseil
départemental pierre bédier en lui
adressant une lettre ouverte
on écoute à la un jason maire de la
verrière pour l'instant je n'en sais
rien nous en sommes nous sommes dans une
période un peu étonnante puisque on
m'avait annoncé la fermeture de la paix
mis au 1er septembre
je constate qu'elle est toujours ouverte
qu'il je n'ai pas reçu d'avis de
fermeture nous sommes à noël
donc j'imagine qu'elle sera encore
ouverte début 2016
je suis un optimiste dont je considère
que c'est plutôt un bon signe qui est
donné en tout cas que tout n'est pas
encore réglé
la ville de coignières a ouvert le 11
décembre dernier son nouveau pôle de
santé pluridisciplinaires cet
établissement qui a ouvert début
novembre remplace l'ancien centre
médical situé rue des étangs qui
n'étaient plus conformes aux nouvelles
lois sur l'accessibilité aux personnes à
mobilité réduite
focus sur ce nouvel établissement une
superficie de 520 mètres carrés un
parking privé de 26 places pour un coût
total d'un million huit cent mille euros
ce nouveau pôle santé
pluridisciplinaires répond à une
nécessité de la ville de coignières de
s'adapter aux besoins de sa population
précédemment nous avions bien sûr un
centre médical et qui était situé rue
des étangs dans un ancien pavillon et
qui n'étaient plus adaptés à aux
personnes notamment à mobilité réduite
et qui n'était plus conforme si vous
voulez aux nouvelles lois concernant le
handicap
ce bâtiment beaucoup plus fonctionnel
bâti de plain pied au niveau
rez-de-chaussée accueillis dès son
ouverture les médecins locataires de
l'ancien centre
dans l'état actuel nous sommes deux
médecins généralistes un gynécologue
en tout huit praticiens médicaux
paramédicaux c'est à dire une kiné des
podologues pour l'instant une partie du
bâtiment est encore disponible à la
location pour de nouveaux praticiens
spécialisés qui manque encore dans la
région pour des raisons de démographie
médicale
malgré l'attractivité de ce nouveau pôle
santé il ya de nombreux besoins qui ne
sont pas satisfaits à coignières par
exemple orthophoniste par exemple
étoffer l'équipe qui n'est par exemple
un dentiste qu'il n'y a plus
malheureusement à coignières et puis
d'autres spécialités comme par exemple
ophtalmo dermato peu rhumatologue que
dans lequel il ya une énorme demande qui
n'est pas satisfaite
ajouté aux anciens patients de la pmi de
coignières désormais fermé de nombreuses
personnes de communes limitrophes se
rendent dans ce pôle santé qui pour
l'instant enregistre déjà une trentaine
de consultation en moyenne par jour à
l'occasion de la journée du handicap le
3 décembre le château de versailles a
organisé une semaine complète dédiée aux
personnes en situation de handicap
une programmation spécialement adaptés
en fonction du type de handicap comme
cette visite théâtralisée sensorielle
destinée aux malvoyants et qui proposait
aux spectateurs de redécouvrir la sphère
du collier de la reine en faisant appel
à tous ses sens reportage c'est un
réglage c'est la reine qui domine les
grands appartements
c'est là que nous allons évoluer parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous allez être les
auditeurs des auditrices les spectateurs
spectatrice d'une visite spectacle mon
sujet et le colis darier aujourd'hui nul
besoin de lumière au château de
versailles
c'est une pièce théâtralisée sensoriel à
laquelle ces personnes malvoyantes sont
venus assister pour une immersion totale
la visite commence par une partie
exposition c'est à dire que les gens
vont au départ toucher les costumes dans
un premier temps et ensuite comme ça ils
savent exactement ce qu'ils ont devant
eux
et puis c'est formidable parce que très
souvent on dit on a toujours envie
touchant dit non non non vous ne touchez
pas où vous toucher avec les yeux mais
pas avec les mains voila et là bas non
là on peut vraiment toucher les choses
la pièce commence et tous les sens du
public sont en éveil
ici pas de convention sans sel ni décor
les comédiens se déplace au milieu des
spectateurs en les effleurant
la couche dans une autre chambre fruit
de l'amour et non la raison je ne suis
pas une princesse je suis une bâtard on
est dans une immersion totale et à une
identification complète avec avec
l'action c'est-à-dire de l'action et
autour de nous on est presque témoins ni
témoin privilégié au cabinet ciel une
pièce qui s'articule autour de quatre
saynètes qui raconte l'histoire du vol
du collier de la reine
les trois comédiens jouent puis laisse
place entre chaque scène un conférencier
poser comme narrateur de l'histoire
je suis en support dans le récit et dans
la précision ou la confirmation d'un
certain nombre de faits de dates de
lieux qui aident à nourrir
l'intrigué surtout sa compréhension vis
du de voter pour cette pièce le château
de versailles a même réalisé une copie
conforme du collier de la reine pour que
le public puisse profiter pleinement de
tous les éléments du spectacle
voyez l'autre possibilité c'est de
sentir par exemple sentir ce que
pourrait être le parfum de marc antoine
est
ou alors possibilité aussi dans un
moment particulier où une dégustation de
café se sentir une odeur de café
on a l'impression d'être dans l'action
on est on est on est c'est très
important et parce que là tous les sens
sont un exemple donc c'est pas c'est
vraiment très bien dans le château ça
nous donne une dimension historique est
vraiment formidable et ma chienne a
participé elle était au coeur de
l'action elle a bien réagi aussi des
contraintes de mise en scène qui pousse
à trouver de nouvelles solutions mais
ici pas besoin de soleil au château pour
que la troupe plonge les auditeurs dans
l'atmosphère de l'époque
et pour égayer le séjour des personnes
hospitalisées l'association rire 78 a
lancé son opération vire pour guérir
l'objectif amener l'humour à des
personnes malades qui vivent des moments
difficiles et qui ne peuvent se rendre
dans les salles de spectacle onze
manifestations ont eu lieu sur
différents établissements du territoire
retour sur la représentation de sophie
forte et régis moreau au centre
hospitalier de versailles
c'est un cadeau avant l'heure pour les
enfants malades du centre hospitalier de
versailles
un spectacle musical et plein d'humour
grâce à l'association greer 78 les
jeunes patients ont pu assister au
concert de sophie forte et son
guitariste régis moreau la chanteuse
également marraine de l'association
participent à l'opération depuis sept
ans sa motivation le bonheur de faire
plaisir de l'agent sa part mme lajoie
façon 11
voilà c'est toujours comme ça c'est un
échange sais pas je n'ai pas que faire
pour faire plaisir aux autres
c'est vrai que quelque part moi aussi ça
me réjouis de pouvoir voilà amusé des
enfants les rendre à un moment un petit
moment ici de faire partir ailleurs en
tout cas l'action rire pour guérir
permet d'apporter des moments d'évasion
aux patients à leurs familles mais
également au personnel soignant
car ces manifestations fédère aussi les
équipes je pense que c'est important
pour les abîmes dossier d'abord tout
simplement parce que dans nos journées
de travail et bien avoir un petit moment
de détente c'est aussi ça fait du bien
et puis c'est aussi notation peuvent se
réunir et de ne pas être d'accord
ensemble pour autre chose
les foins les soins techniques par
l'arrêt des traitements à l'enfant une
trentaine d'enfants étaient présents
pour marquer une pause festive dans leur
quotidien après des débuts timides le
public s'est laissé emporter par les
mélodies entraînantes
c'est super gentil pour les gens qui
viennent pas
distraire ouais c'est sympa ça nous ça
fait oublier un peu tous les problèmes
qu'on ait ou non mais franchement
c'était génial
cette représentation était la dernière
des onze manifestations de ce type qui
ont eu lieu dans différents hôpitaux et
cliniques du département pour la fin
d'année et pour terminer beaucoup
d'entre nous compte certainement on
aurait copieusement les fêtes de fin
d'année alors après cette période qui
est rarement propice aux repas
équilibrés mais plutôt synonyme d'
excellent régime a adopté cf porsche est
diététicienne à chaville qui nous
apporte ses réponses au micro de camille
lambert après les fêtes c'est bien
mettre un peu son foie effectivement au
repos et aller vers des aliments plutôt
frais des fruits des légumes de saison à
manger plus léger mais naturellement si
on s'écoute bien on n'a plus envie non
plus
après les repas de fêtes de pas de
continuer sur un rythme aussi voilà
aussi riche vous l'avez compris il ne
faut pas non plus se restreindre dès le
mois de janvier si vous voulez terminer
les restes ou simplement continuer à
vous faire plaisir
l'important c'est surtout d'étaler les
aliments gras sur plusieurs repas et si
comme moi vous conter garder la ligne
fait surtout attention aux quantités
comme la plupart des français vous
comptez certainement déboucher une
petite bouteille à noël ou en sabre et
plusieurs au nouvel an est fort chez
vous apporte ses petites astuces pour
éviter les lendemains difficiles
c'est vraiment aussi d'avoir des moments
où un peu d'eau pour parce qu'on sent
qu'on a on a peut-être
besoin de s'hydrater et et garder
vraiment l'alcool sur les moments où on
a envie d'associer ses arômes avec
l'aliment que l'on vient de manger
changer de vin monde c'est de se servir
plutôt des deux univers où apprendre
plein de vins différents pour associer
avec ses aliments voilà c'est de
calculer un petit peu sont ces plaisirs
et ce que l'on aime bien pour qu'à la
fin du repas on sont pas malades où il
compose des fêtes aussi en bonne santé
avec plein d'énergie
vous l'avez compris l'essentiel et de
modérer sa consommation d'alcool qui je
le rappelle est dangereux pour la santé
vous avez maintenant toutes les clés en
main pour éviter la traditionnelle
gueule de bois du 1er janvier
voilà check up c'est maintenant terminé
quant à moi il ne me reste plus qu'à
vous souhaiter de bonnes fêtes et
surtout prenez soin de vous